I miss the thumbs up okay great hi
everybody sorry for that kind of awkward
transition my name is still apply
I am a mathematical statistician working
in this really link we named sub organ
of the United States Census Bureau you
can just think of it as it's sort of the
area census that is responsible for
disclosure avoidance concerns and that
has sort of adopted differentially
private methods for a lot of our current
initiatives going forward so this is a
quick description of just a number of
the folks I work with this is not an
exhaustive list I kind of selected the
subset of people who spend most of their
time working with with me and other
folks on mathematical theory a privacy
theory implementation of code and and
also sort of manipulating the data
sources that we work with and so I think
maybe not all of you but some of you may
be familiar with Johnny about he's the
the Project Lead kind of set sort of
high level of visionary decisions for
the project someone else that I probably
should call out is Dan Kiefer down here
in the academic partners section he's
the scientific lead and has made some
sort of high-level algorithmic decisions
for the way in which we're processing
our data and trying to actually
implement the final final DP mechanism
that we're developing so what I intend
to talk about today is first this what
split up into sort of these three major
areas first what is the 2020 disclosure
avoidance system so - is kind of the
acronym that we throw around number
talking about the system we're building
and that's actually not the point of the
talk although it will take us a while to
get through the point of that is to
probably provide sort of context and
motivation for the practical obstacles
that I'll talk out about I thought the
latter half of the talk and then we'll
jump into two classes of practical
obstacles like what I want to discuss
that I think to some extent understudied
and it may be like we can draw a little
bit more attention to them
so first is challenges that occur in
estimating error and second is I'm
really terribly named topic challenges
with practical implementation and so I
really struggled to come up with a
better name than practical
implementation issues for that second
category but hopefully when we get to
that section it'll be kind of clear what
I mean by that and then in the end I'm
going to just stop and say oh also
there's a lot of other stuff that I
wanted to talk about but couldn't talk
about because an hour wasn't enough time
and so I'll probably linger on that
slide if he hadn't just let folks there
so what are we doing at census and what
we have we've been have we been doing
for say the past two years on this
project so our goal is to develop a
formal a private census whereby formerly
private I don't mean differentially
private specifically although
differentially private algorithms will
perform like sort of the primary
subroutine that it confers privacy for
the algorithm but but formally private
in the sense that there should be some
rigorous mathematical proof for broad
classes of attackers that has a clear
privacy guarantee in the usual sense
that you've that user to encounter in
the DP literature I'm gonna talk about
in a sec aunt just make the claim that
it's fully DP so before we do that and
we'll actually get into it with
well-well-well and working down this
list there are sort of a number of
structural decisions you guys are made
or had imposed upon us or so we're sort
of requested of us as we were designing
the DES the this first little list here
sort of the list of inputs that we're
expecting that ask the taken so the
first of these is is the set the census
edited file you can just think of this
as the other sensitive input data so
this is the 300 million odd records for
persons that we're collecting and
there's also you know hundred million or
so odd records for households that are
collected as part of that same input
source and so this is the sensitive
input data that we were interested in
protecting and also in which we are
interested in preserving reasonable
amounts of utility and accuracy for
end-users on there is a second class of
inputs here that I refer to as
invariants this is sort of a term that
we have developed internally for
discussing this this particular class of
queries and this is the reason I can't
claim that the system is end-to-end
differentially private so these queries
which I'm not going to talk too much
about today unless people have questions
about them or want to talk about them
afterwards these are your queries that
just we are not allowed to infuse any
noise into them and so when we generate
our eventual micro data which is what
we're going to produce internally that
micro data has to agree exactly with the
original staff on the values of the
invariants and yet we wish to model sort
of our responsibility for releasing the
information associated we deal with
these invariants and because of that we
have to modify some of the standard
semantic guarantees and some one sort of
the high level claims we make about the
the privacy guarantees of the end-to-end
system as you
can you point out which invariants are
legally mandated and which aren't there
for other reasons like because it was
too big of a headache to argue about or
something like that so we're not going
to get too much into the details of the
invariants today I can say by way of
example that there will most likely be
an invariant for the national population
as well as invariance for the
state-level populations whether those
are legally mandated or not is a sort of
fraught question that I am not the right
person to sort of decisively answer but
there are clearly legal concerns
associated with those quantities there
are also other classes of invariants
that maybe get into the second category
you mentioned which are not in any sense
legally mandated but which are sort of a
kind of unavoidable given the way
processes currently work so the category
I usually go to for this example is we
have a look at to this in a second we
have a bunch of tabulations that are
published about what are called group
quarters facilities so these are
tabulations about people that live
inside college dormitories military
bases that that sort of kind of
large-scale group structure because of
the way those queries are actually
collected in practice and I don't think
I'm really great person to get too much
into detail about how that works but
because of the way they're collected in
practice working with sort of members of
the communities that are relevant that
information is kind of already publicly
released or in the public domain in some
sense and so there's not really a way
for us that certainly not at this point
and in the processing to call that
information back and sort of say no no
we're not going to we're gonna hold that
behind the privacy barrier that isn't
something we can do at this point in
addition there are also there there's a
larger class of sort of potential
invariants that are kind of under
discussion so one example of this is
that there there has been discussion
about whether or not the number of
persons who are a voting age or non
voting age with an individual Geographic
unit should be held in a variant there
have been similar discussions about
whether the total number of households
in a geographic unit should be held in
Maryann's or whether the total number of
households that are occupied should be
held in a variant and so there are a lot
of decisions kind of swirling around
exactly what the set of invariants will
finally look like and actually the the
uncertainty about what that sets finally
going to look like is driven a lot of
our design decisions and controlled a
lot of the the work that we've done in
trying to make sure that we can
anticipate whatever those are eventually
going to what form they're going to take
so hopefully that just addresses most of
what you're asking about course
anyway there is a third major input here
which I will refer to as the workload
and denote by W I'm borrowing this
language from the matrix mechanism paper
if you all are familiar with that you
can just think of it as a set of queries
in which we are attempting to minimize
error so these are the queries on which
we are going to sort of with our noisy
differentially private measurements
attempt to get decent fit but it won't
be exact as as in the case with the
invariance okay so so given these these
inputs are you using variances to be
sure your software isn't dropping one
you know how to roll up various stages
and that's a common common checking
procedure do you have things like that
or is there wall behind you can keep
that stuff I'm not sure I entirely
follow the question could you elaborate
a little bit we introduced 999 new
records and the count goes up quite a
thousand that Choshu you had a bit you
hat that's a common sort of transient
error in building software that is
absorbing stuff all the time
so does that survive or you lose the
ability to look for those little
glitches so this is actually one of the
practical implementation difficulties
that I kind of want to discuss a little
bit later in the presentation because it
is exactly the kind of thing where we
are interested in being able to hunt for
bugs that may have generated errors that
are sort of abnormally large and sort of
unreasonable size and that suggests that
there's an error in the implementation
that being said we can't readily do that
by just jumping into the V true data and
jumping into the final produced
microdata that's privatized and
comparing them directly to one another
because if we do that and then we start
making changes on the basis of that
process we've sort of introduced a
feedback loop and and the final
randomness that governs the actual
outputs is no longer necessarily
governed by the VP definition it ends up
being governed by sort of our subjective
interventions to try and control those
kinds of errors but we'll talk a little
bit about that I don't know that I will
have any satisfying answer for that
question we'll talk a little bit more
about it okay so given these inputs
there there are some expectations that
we're trying to meet as far as the form
of the outputs that we're producing and
sort of the properties they'll have
the most important of these I think is
that we are expected to generate
microdata there are a few reasons for
this one of the most important ones is
that it fits really nicely into internal
processing pipelines so folks are
already a sort of accustomed to dealing
with microdata a second so sort of maybe
less convenient space stories and is
that it also allows us to ensure that
there's consistency between the queries
were publishing in a really easy way and
that they don't sort of look strange in
various cases so you want to make sure
that there there are negative queries
floating around in the tabulations that
we publish that tends to be a difficult
thing to explain when you're talking to
especially a non-technical audience
about why that estimate was produced and
where when you're trying to interpret it
in some sort of more concrete sense I
also have two other requirements listen
to the very end here this is really just
the restatement of sort of what
invariants are intended to represent and
also a statement that when you look at
the way the data is organized at least
for the the first few doubt of products
this may not be its final form but for
the first few data products that ass is
going to look like generating microd add
a detail file this MDF is the Micra
gather we're generating which will pop
out of an algorithm known as the dass
which takes as inputs the workload
because it needs to know what it's
trying to get low err on but will also
take us inputs the true values of the
invariants evaluated on the SEF so
evaluated on the of the underlying true
data and which will also take out so
measurements evaluated on the SEF as
well so so DP noisy measurements
estimates of the those queries that
we're interested in trying to get low
error on there any further questions
about the slide No
okay so jumping in she was a work a
little bit more I think in attempting to
motivate and explain what we're working
on and sort of the problems that have
popped up one of the easiest ways to
grapple with the project and sort of I
come to understand how it operates is to
first start with up with what the
problem looks like and what the
structure of our workload is because
that's really where most of the
structure of the problem comes from so
the workloads or rather the queries and
the workload are organized along a
number of different different dimensions
so first they are organized in sort of a
geographic dimension that they live
inside Geographic units which live
inside Geographic levels and those have
sort of their own structure that we'll
talk about in a slider too in addition
as I sort of already kind of alluded to
and answering one of the early questions
there are two kinds of records at
two kinds of records that we're dealing
with there are person level records that
we have to address queries on as well as
queries that are sort of about units so
about the people who live in a household
that have a householder who is of a
particular race that is a common example
of a query in the second class and in
addition there are I think not so much
for reporters facilities but at least
for households there are literal counts
of a number of households satisfying
certain properties and so we have a
number of sort of group queries and
person level queries usually be reasoned
about sensitivity by thinking about
neighboring databases in terms of
alterations to to individual persons not
to individual households so this is one
these are just the first two ways in
which the workload is organized moving
on a little more we then and this is
actually how I sort of day-to-day think
about the actual algorithms were
building and sort of how much progress
we have or haven't made in what major
milestones we still have to meet the the
releases that we intend on producing are
then typically organized into four major
data products and roughly ten additional
smaller data products the for small data
crowd or the four major data products
our peel menu for s f1 s f2 and ains F
PL 94 stands for public law 94-142 and
used for political redistricting and so
usually when you think about
constitutional mandates or sort of the
strongest legislative requirements they
tend to pertain immediately to this data
product this is the smallest of the four
major data products but it also tends to
have the lowest Geographic rather the
resolution of them it includes clearly
is like how many people are though that
are a voting age in a particular
geographic unit when people are that
they're non voting age in a particular
Geographic unit how many people are
there in a geographic unit that reported
having a being of three races of four
races of five races within the six meter
race categories that are reported in the
census and there are a few other queries
in there as well
the next major data product stepping on
up from that is summary file one summary
file one is very similar to peel 94 but
bigger so summary file one takes the
kind of demographic information that
appears in NPL 94 and it says well for
example you only had voting age non
voting age in PL 94 as it turns out
there's a wide range of user communities
that are interested in having a lot more
detail in the age distribution than that
and so summary file one at the census
tract level which is a geographic unit
we'll talk about in a second I just
think of it as not the lowest level a
little bit above the lowest low
at that level salary summary file one in
2010 contain tables that were at single
year resolution of age and so it would
count like the number of persons who are
of age 37 and male in a particular
geographic unit and it's sort of
generally just sort of had it takes the
dimensions that were impaled 94 adds a
number of dimensions to them and
increases the resolution within each
dimension while still building down to
the lowest Geographic level in some
cases higher geographic levels in a few
other cases and it's usually it's spread
across the census block census tract and
County levels and again we'll talk about
the geographic hierarchy in a second
okay should have put that slide before
this one but so let's jump on to summary
file two so summary file two is is an
actually a minus F let's treat them
together so summary file two is sort of
a detailed race version of summary file
one and ains F is sort of a detailed
tribe version of summary file one both
of these data products take a subset of
tables from sf1 and they say okay you
had whatever the variables were in the
table originally and you sort of form
the full cross of them and counted all
of those individuals that besides fell
into each of those buckets we're now
going to take each of those tables and
for sf2 we're going to cross them by the
one of 500 or so individual detail
braces and for AI NS f we're going to do
the same thing but cost them now by one
of about 1,500 individual detailed
tribes the geographic resolution is
coarser through these two products than
it is for the first two products but I
think you can already see both from the
level of detail that's sort of popping
up in those those race and tribe
dimensions as well as I will talk about
a second about the number of Geographic
units there are how we're getting to
these large numbers that I had sitting
next to each of the data products
so I could show you the full list um but
I'm not an expert on how the list is
actually actually cultivated and sort of
originally created that's maybe a good
question for us to sort of circle back
around afterwards when I can actually go
to a like that really the relevant
resources is it counts combinations that
are a if you say there's multiple just
so there is a little bit of against the
short answer is yes by in the in the sf2
and a NSF products those those the the
numbers that I just quoted the 500 the
1500 those are not because it's taking
all possible subsets of a set then
whatever because there are roughly I
think 250 ish individual detailed races
and then you get roughly roughly twice
that because it asks about them
individually and it also asks about them
and whether or not you also reported
being something else so there is the
detailed race alone and the diesel
racing combination with some other race
this is excluding the major O&B race
categories which is I think what you may
be thinking of the major OMB race
categories there are only six of the
binary Flags for them and those will
contribute to both pl 94 and SF 1 not
just six sort of levels in a dimension
but 63 levels in the dimension and that
is because in these two products those
major race categories you do form sort
of all possible subsets of them and look
at each of the subsets from the ACS it
is not from the ACS no it's a right and
there are item lengths on the decennial
census form and folks can use the
write-in blanks to indicate well so I'm
not I don't consider myself psycho
justification I also consider myself
Italian where I'm Jack dorso some other
sort of detail race category that can be
listed and I can show you the actual of
a list of them for 2010 maybe after the
talk so the key point here is the pearce
a lot of data products with a lot of
tabulations and then that have been
published historically these counts here
are actually kind of a mix of what the
historical estimates look like and sort
of what I sort of currently expect vivir
future looking a number of tabulations
to look like for peel menu for nsf1
these two counts those are those are
reasonably close to sort of what I
expect to be confronting for 2024 these
other three categories it's still a
little bit more up in the air this one
mostly just because I realized this
morning my code wasn't doing
quite what I thought it was doing these
two because these products are so large
that traditional methods will not work
with them and and we also I think that
census are probably going to end up
having a fairly hard conversation about
whether it's actually possible to deal
with simply the sheer number of and
complexity of those tabulations
so I guess penal and accord is needed
for specifically good reason
redistricting this specific legally
required use cases for the other three
or we give them because we like to share
a bit it's really hard to give a terse
answer to that so the reality is that
there is not sort of a single
centralized database that collects all
of the legal justifications for an or
uses of each of the individual
tabulations that are published in the
census so that's kind of a murky answer
but it is also the case that these other
products s f1 s f2 and ains F are many
of their tabulations I would be
hard-pressed to sort of extemporaneously
identify all of them but many of their
tabulations are used in the execution of
various laws whether those laws at the
state or federal level or county level
sometimes call for using that product
specifically or they just say sort of
use the best available thing and they
default but the Sonny l census is sort
of a hard thing to get good statistical
information on but so the answer is you
got stand now
so is there somebody is there an instant
institutional memory of which wars were
fought by the definitions in categories
2 3 & 4 I think there is an
institutional memory of recent issue
over the past decade or two
conversations about individual
tabulations but I would not go as far as
calling it an institutional memory for
the war fought over every individual
tabulation I don't know that there is
sort of like a log file which is just
petabytes and petabytes long that
describes all of the individual
conversations let's around to be to the
individual tabulations the recent effort
we made to try and gather some of this
information so there's also only
something else to be said about this -
before before I jump on part of our
effort so learn a bit more about how
this is being used because a lot of this
sort of once it leaves censuses borders
and ends up being repackaged by other
organizations so that gate bums is a
very large repackage of data that's
published by the Census once that
information gets out into the world it's
used in a lot of ways that we should
have have no immediate ability to track
and so even stepping away from like
specifically statutory uses of the data
also really important to understand well
I mean how researchers using the data
how how are medical organizations using
the data how are cities using without it
to make planning decisions and so we had
a federal registry notice that went out
to try and gather some about information
and we got something useful feedback but
I think there's still definitely a need
for us to engage more thoroughly with
sort of the external expert user
community about a lot of the use cases
we've got partial answer to your
question so I think this is probably
obvious everybody but we have about
three hundred million person records
about a hundred million household
records given the sheer number of
tabulations that you can see sort of her
further up on the slide it can be
expected that most of those tabulations
are going to have an answer at zero
there's really no way around that
short of just making them all exactly
the same tabulation which I can assure
you folks did not do so this is the
geographic lattice I probably would talk
a little bit more about I don't wanna
spend too much time on it this is a
really helpful visualization that you
can get by going to the census geography
website so I literally went there and
sir sweetie captured it it shows you all
of the different geographic levels that
are used sort of in common parlance and
application at census and for us a
particular importance will be this sort
of central geo path as I refer to it
which drops from nation to States to
county is to tract to groups in the
blocks and there's also kind of a
mystery there so we're going to within
the des walk down that hierarchy in the
generation of our micro data product and
that that will sort of dominate the
organization of the algorithm these
other other areas are also quite
important and then sort of there are
some questions for me at least about
whether we can find a way to explicitly
spend what I will refer to throughout
the talk has privacy lost budget so if
expenditure of DTP epsilon on targeting
accuracy on some of these other these
other geographic areas but it's maybe
important to call out that a key
property of this lattice is essentially
everything can be built from census
blocks so you can think of census blocks
is sort of the atomic unit from every
which everything else is constructed
there are also a few other features of
this this chart that would be worth
observing so certain of these areas
urban areas for example don't partition
the nation so not every area in the
nation is urban this is this is sort of
a bunch of non exhaustive subsets of the
nation and beach you can think of as
aggregations of blocks and so throughout
the talk I'll refer to these as a geo
units things like Texas that live inside
geo levels things like States
one other thing to mention of
this this sort of picture is this is
where a lot of the scale in the work
Libby looked that comes from so in
particular at the census block level
there are something like 10 million
census blocks that's a really crude
approximation and a John might actually
poke me a bit for if you're using so
different approximation but that you can
find that online that's that sort of
it's a good order of magnitude estimate
of how many census blocks there are and
that's how we get into the billions with
a lot of those figures
okay so I've talked a lot about things
that make our problem hard and sort of
like the complex structure of our
problem I should also mention that we do
have a few things that make our problem
somewhat easier which are rather nice so
some that are less nice but the thing is
that was nice that I'm thinking of is
that most of our queries are low
sensitivity counting queries in the
usual differentially private sense the
usual sense that that term is used in
the literature we also have some sort of
high sensitivity queries on person h h
GQ joins which are sort of noisy
measurements we would like to take in
order to figure out well if we're going
to be asked to take people and put them
into households and provide the ability
to join the two micro data files if
we're going to be asked to do that then
this is a class of queries we would have
to face down I'm probably not the right
person to speak to methods for doing
that some of our academic partners have
some ideas about it but it's still sort
of a topic of conversation and we've all
read also pitched sir to some some
heuristics for trying to alter the
workload in a way that would make these
things sort of analogous to what they
are but lower in sensitivity in addition
they're also non-linear queries medians
and means which I don't think we have
any present plans to try and directly
target them the privacy loss budget but
the medians and means we for the most
part they can be expressed as nonlinear
transformations of the counting queries
so I think we have at least ways to
support expressing queries on them and
tabulations over them from the final
microdata but I don't think we're
getting spending hobbies last budget
directly on them and then this table at
the end is just a a simple example that
you can get if you google sf1 PDF 2010
technical documentation there is a
600-page technical documentation
document you can drop down into chapter
6 subsection 3 it's the data dictionary
section that section has a whole lot of
tables that look like this and so you
can just see this table says nsf1 tell
me how many people there were who
reported being of two or more of the six
major OMB race categories tell me how
many people there were reported of the
being
of that type in total tell me how many
of those folks there were who were male
tell me how many of those folks there
were who were male in under five years
and also in each of these individual age
buckets so this is sort of a concrete
example of some of the tabulations that
we're dealing with okay so given the the
complex structure that we just kind of
looked at how do we actually go about
trying to contend with that in practice
well the way the tax organizes its work
is it actually does it very similarly to
the way to leave clean up this
conversation so far so it works
currently over sort of pairs of major
data products and record types and for
each major data probably a product which
is something like peel 94 s f1 s f2 or a
I NSF and record type which is something
like persons or quarters facilities or
rather persons or household / group
quarters facilities for each of those
combinations we form a simple schema
that just says this is the universe of
all possible record types that we could
observe within this data product so a
simple way to form this four PL 94 is
just to say PL 94 needs to support
queries that could be expressed over
record types that look like person as
how their voting age or not voting age
they are in one of eight categories for
H htq either they're in households or
they're in one of the seven major group
quarters of facility types his ethnicity
is whether you reported being Hispanic
or not Hispanic and then race is kind of
I think something I referred to before
when Anand asked the question this is
the the all possible subsets of the 6
race major race categories with one of
them lopped off because there's an edit
constraint that says you shouldn't be
reporting we shouldn't be preserving
that you recorded having no race and so
it sort of insistent imputing a race in
there and so you get 63 instead of 64
possibilities okay so given this set up
which allows us within a particular data
product and record type we can then
focus on an individual Geographic unit
again something like Texas in in the set
of states and for that Geographic unit
for this current data product we can say
okay now we can express all possible
record types we have we're then going to
generate a histogram that represents the
Micra data that we want to produce for
this particular geographic unit the I'm
not I'm not being terribly specific here
about the particular measurements we're
going to take for that Geographic unit
and part this because there's an
algorithm that determines that we'll
talk about it in a second but a key
point that I want to sort of highlight
here is that these histogram objects can
be not surprisingly quite expensive to
store especially what they were handling
right now which is we are storing most
of them explicitly in memory and you can
sort of wander along in an increasing
order the
combinations of data products and record
types we have and you can see how
quickly these grow now if we had to
store just a single sort of 85 million
64-bit floating-point numbers numpy and
DRA that wouldn't be such a big deal the
problem is these numbers tend to get
multiplied by the number of geographic
units that are contained in an immediate
immediately in the geographic unit that
contains them so like all the counties
in Texas for example and sometimes that
fan-out can can become very very large
and can multiply these numbers by you
know 100 or a thousand or something and
so you quickly end up I think a million
64-bit floating-point numbers is
something like point zero seven gigs
which is not not terribly expensive but
when you start multiplying it by 10 and
100 or a thousand you quickly get into
round figures that are a bit more
concerning we're a lot more concerning
when you start seeing brand exceptions
thrown so why are we insisting on using
these histogram objects given that
they're very expensive and in general
you don't necessarily need to rely on
them there are a few reasons they're not
really all listed here but the quick
ones that I have are it's easy to
guarantee you that the limit as epsilon
runs to infinity of the - it will be the
true input data and this while it may
not be a terribly important feature in
terms of general applications and when
you have sort of a quick list of the
queries you're interested in for
interpretive purposes and working with
sort of the folks who are going to
actually set the privacy loss budget
which will not be us but will be
executive sort of several levels above
my head for working with those folks and
explaining to them hey this is how our
system works it's really convenient to
be able to say well if you were maybe
you won't but if you were to take your
epsilon and make it as big as humanly
possible before if you went out of the
ability to express that in that number
in the relevant data type you would get
this F back and so there is at least
this sort of rough interpolation
property in the limit in addition to
working with these histograms is and
this is probably the more important of
the few reasons I think we probably
could get the the limiting condition
without worrying about without storing
these histograms all explicitly really
the bigger reason that we need to work
with them is given the complex set of
invariants that we've had to deal with
and we've had to sort of try and make an
algorithm that can produce feasible data
under that turns out unless you want to
code up your own sort of
state-of-the-art convex optimizer that
turns out to be a lot easier if you can
express variables that are sufficient
for actually detailing all of the
structure of these invariants and the
simplest way to do that is just
access to the full histogram of possible
record types because I allow you to sort
of express arbitrary and bearing and
sort or linear expressions okay
continuing a little bit more on how the
- sort of organized its labor I said
before it walks down the central geo
path within the central geo path we the
reason we're moving top-down on the sort
of the motivation for it is that this
does a much better job than for example
starting at the bottom and kind of
independently handling each block and
then sort of aggregating with the other
it avoids the linear blow-up invariants
I thought that that would contribute and
instead uses sort of borrowers strengths
to try and improve the accuracy as we
move down the tree by using patterns
that are easier to detect higher up in
the geographic hierarchy so that's why
we're moving top down in sort of a quick
sketch you can think sort of an in
pseudocode of the way the dash works for
a particular data product a record type
combination in in really two phases and
then sort of a looping phase the first
thing is is it's going to take all of
the measurements for all of the
geographic units over the entire
hierarchy that you're interested in it
will do this using something known as
the high dimensional matrix mechanism
which this talk is not about but I
believe there's at least a conference
paper that you can google and pick up
pretty quickly some of our academic
partners put together this algorithm it
is a refinement of the matrix mechanism
that is intended specifically to
approximate the kinds of strategies in
the structure we see in sort of the
tabulation sets we're interested in
publishing and to use the structure that
we can find in those tabulations to
scale up the matrix mechanism to much
larger sizes than than is really
feasible with sort of the actual matrix
mechanism or sort of common variants of
it given that you have these
measurements we now move into a sort of
phase 2.1 various 2.1 is well we don't
have any microdata yet so starting at
the national level let us build an
optimization model that will allow us to
sort of perform inference and that
inference will consist of generating a
micro Dada's detail file for the nation
but is consistent with the invariants we
have at the national level and that is
also fitted to sort of the observed
estimates of these workload queries
given the measurements that we took
there is a little bit being hidden here
and then asterisks it turns out it's
actually not sufficient to fit just to
the invariants at the national level
there is information you have to
percolate up from the block level or you
start running into all kinds of
infeasibility infeasible optimization
problems all over the place and that was
a headache for quite a long time but we
don't talk about that today so I won't
say any
worried about that unless folks want to
talk about it after finally we just sort
of repeat this process so now for every
to you you net where you currently have
an end EF and you don't have an MDF for
its children go ahead and generate the
MDS for children by solving a
large-scale simultaneous optimization
problem that does inference over all of
those children fruit for that gio unit
this is just another visualization of
what we've already said I don't want to
linger on this very much but make
anything after the nation been
simultaneously for all the states given
that you know what the nation looks like
then for each state for all the counties
in that state keep in that state looks
like etc etc okay so as I think I've
sort of hurriedly said a few times this
is a very maybe I haven't um this is a
very abbreviated description of how the
nest works a longer talk specifically
about the - would focus more on it I
know what the transition to sort of when
I was asked to talk about which is sort
of practical obstacles that we've
encountered and working with and
developing the DES and so I'll just say
there's still a lot left that has to be
done and decided but we have gotten a
lot done and we've also run into some
interesting obstacles along the way so I
will talk about two classes of obstacles
that same two I mentioned before so I
won't repeat them and these are those
two classes of issues this to remind you
the first is sort of error estimation
and how we're going to present error
estimates to our end user community and
the second is implementation issues
which is sort of my catch-all term for
not being able to come up with a more
creative and precise name for what
consists what implementation issues
consists oh okay so error estimation
error estimation is something that
frankly we haven't had a ton of time to
work on to date but having considered
our options we can see there are going
to be some fairly significant problems
and trying to figure out how best to do
it but we're really at least I'm really
excited about it because I think it
should be one of the sort of key sales
points for for using a formally private
approach among sort of general user
communities we couldn't do this with
prior methods we couldn't publish our
code that we use to do da we couldn't
and I think I'm preaching to the
audience probably largely here but we
couldn't publish our code we couldn't
tell people the parameter settings we
were using and we certainly couldn't
provide sort of precise well described
estimates of the error or the structure
of the error that we were infusing we
want to be able to do that because
that's not the point but it is a nice
side benefit of adopting formally
private methods
unfortunately doing this poses some hard
questions and I think these last two
things are little bit redundant so I'll
talk about them a second
so why is it hard to do this in practice
well I mean the most obvious thing we
could do is just say we have this
gigantic workload that consists of like
150 billion tabulations that we might
possibly try to publish if we do that
are we just going to go to every single
one of them and try and publish an error
estimate associated with it and for some
but that's actually that could be okay
so if the method you're using has like a
nice closed form for the error
associated with it that is independent
of the underlying data and there are
lots of examples of this in the DP
literature then you're kind of in a good
place and you could just say okay I'm
just literally it's cheap usually to
compute these I'll just go to every
query and publish an estimate of the
error and you're sort of sort of done is
maybe a strong word but you've you've
accomplished the primary task at that
point a good example of this is the -
this reliance on HTML I'm sort of a
quarter of it HTM is is sort of again a
refinement of the matrix mechanism and
in the last step what you're doing is
just taking linear combinations of noisy
measurements that pop out of the Laplace
mechanism or the geometric mechanism or
whatever other primitive mechanism you
want to sort of insert at that final
step so if that were all we were doing
we would actually I think being in a
pretty good place as far as generating
with these sets of error estimates that
were interested in unfortunately error
estimates of that kind within the
algorithmic design would miss a whole
lot of what we're doing and not reflects
sort of end to end what the error is
actually going to look like after the
complex post-processing and also these
sort of complex incorporation of
invariants that we're doing so in
particular they wouldn't reflect
non-negativity certain on they get you
to be performing that non negative
inference as far as I know there is no
nice sort of closed form for what that
error is going to look like for
incorporating invariance at the same
time which are sort of fundamentally
data dependent for incorporating
integrality which is always a headache
whenever imagers are a part of your
requirement things can become difficult
for proceeding top-down this is actually
something I think we could remove so if
we in isolation focused on the top-down
issue we could actually sort of probably
adjust
htmls error estimates and insert if it's
it's our MSE expressions to reflect the
fact that we're doing this top-down work
but we can't do it at the same time that
we do these things in the first category
and finally so from conversations
internally with a lot of the folks who
are responsible for data review and you
have more expertise being closer to the
data the boss
it is sort of apparent that while
absolute error which is what HD mmm sort
of focuses on optimizing it is important
a lot a lot of our external reviewers
and experts intuition is also
sort of about relative error as well and
this is this is the sort of varies
depending on the size of the underlying
query
not just the relative area but also
whether they care about relative error
absolute error but none are going to
incorporate this we need something like
an look at the data and that's not what
a data independent closed-form is going
to give us so I guess at the risk of
confusing all the users you could just
publish the results of the HTML part
which will give your values which are
not necessarily consistent but at least
unbiased and have good error estimates
doing something like that
so when you say publish the numbers that
are the result of the HTML part do you
mean just the raw estimates themselves
not the final Micra data so we have or
at least I have and I've tried to push
people to maybe consider that I don't
know where we sit as far as that
decision is concerned right now my
inclination is to sort of push for the
more categories of information we can
provide with important caveats and flags
about which sort of group of users we're
expecting to find that useful and not
confusing
I would like to lean more towards
releasing that information than not
releasing that information but
ultimately not my decision so considered
but not decided
okay so there is at least there actually
several other approaches but the one on
the other one I wanna talk about today
is there's at least one of their obvious
approach for addressing some of the
shortcomings of just having those
closed-form expressions that miss a lot
of the categories of information that
are involved and that's we could spend a
privacy loss budget Epsilon explicitly
estimating the l1 or l2 or whatever or
whatever class of areas you're
interested in we could spend it
explicitly estimating the error on a
bunch of our queries and if we do that
that helps in some sense it does give us
for whatever period we target it gives
us you know immediate end and estimates
of error with I think there are fewer
structural assumptions people expect of
us for these final error estimates so it
wouldn't have to do any like crazy
complex post-processing of them and so
we could just stop and say hey here's
the simple distributional description of
the error that is in this error estimate
and I think that would actually be quite
nice but of course this comes the
problems to most obviously it costs
privacy lost budget and we are already
running a little thin on that given that
we have 150 billion queries that have
been floated as sort of a conversation
piece and that sort of poses the same
question as indicating or specifying the
workload in the first place which is
okay we have this massive complex
workload W how do we now go about
choosing which hues to spend privacy
lost budget on to estimate errors given
that we already know it's sort of a
gargantuan task to decide how to do that
just for specifying the workload in the
first place and that's sort of an
obvious problem I feel like there also
something slightly more subtle not super
subtle but slightly more subtle problems
that also occur or at least questions
that are raised so if we do spread this
part this privacy less budget so say we
take our original noisy measurements on
the things that we want to get low error
on and treating a differential accredit
manner we then do our complex
post-processing they got the final micro
data that we want to actually produce at
the end of the process and then we spend
extra privacy lost budget estimating
error on a bunch of the queries that we
just produced or that are of interest
over that micro data those queries now
of course have information they carry
information about the true underlying
data right so we're then tempted to say
well we don't want to throw a privacy
loss budget away let's now use those to
improve the Micro data that we use them
as an estimate of the error on relative
to the true data but if we do that then
the estimates are no longer good
estimates of how well the micro data is
doing and so we kind of entered the
spoon this feedback loop right and it's
also a really expensive feedback loop
because you're spending privacy lost
budget every time you step forward in it
and so it's not totally clear to me what
like a nice satisfying resolution is to
that question there's also at least one
other category of concern I had here
which is that
supposing we do both of these things in
some measure they have sort of different
characteristics things they sort of some
have advantages and disadvantages in
different areas how do we maybe combine
them in some way that could be useful or
do we just publish both of them and say
hey here sort of in our experiments and
analyses here's where we think this
performs well nor this doesn't perform
well and so there's an interesting
question surrounding how should this
multiplicity of error estimation
methodologies that we have available to
us be marshaled together in a way that
will be coherent for external audiences
and will compensate for the
disadvantages of VAP different
approaches hopefully not magnify the
disadvantages okay so that sort of does
it for error estimation and I think are
actually doing okay on time which shocks
me a little bit so that covers the error
estimation sort of practical problems
topic now I'm going to jump into the
implementation issues topic which again
terrible name but hopefully it'll be
clear what I mean so I'm gonna sort of
articulate two major categories of
practical issues that I thought I group
under this this topic one our policy
issues which I really can't say it
better like I think that huh and I wrote
it down here they emerged exactly
because in a large statistical
organization there's a huge number of
people involved in generating if it's a
large product anyway and generating any
individual large product and so there's
certainly a large number of people
involved in done during the decennial
census given that and also that they're
not all going to sit down and study and
carry about and become passionate about
differential privacy it can be very
difficult to get to sort of figure out
what sorts of rules need to be
articulated and imposed to make sure
that we don't accidentally release more
encode in our other releases some sort
of non formally private information
about the data product so this is one
class of concerns a second class which I
think has actually been looked at in
various ways in the literature before is
that there are often mismatches between
these sort of mathematical idealizations
the information theoretic idealizations
that we tend to work with in practice
when describing our DP mechanisms and
the actual implementations that we use
and so I'll talk a little bit about that
as well and some low-level issues we
encountered I won't I don't think
answer how to how to fix all of those
problems but hopefully just call more
attention to them okay so this is just
like a quick run-through of I think what
I already said which is that in a large
stats organization generating something
like the decennial census there's a lot
of people involved and also they
common instinct for someone who is
accustomed to doing data quality review
and who knows that you're sort of
building this really fancy new algorithm
that is based on an entirely new
methodology a common instinct is to say
well I want to make sure you didn't
screw up and for example I think as I
was asked earlier in the talk I want to
make sure you didn't introduce really
large errors that should be signals that
there's something funding something
going wrong and so a natural instinct is
well I want to look at the true data the
Ceph and I want to compare it directly
subjectively manually to the MDF the
final privatized data and then I want to
compare the two and say whoa like that
block looks really crazy that doesn't
seem okay and then I want to kind of
talk about that and escalate that and
discuss it and sort of see how can we
fix this the only problem is this is
sort of blatantly non differentially
private right you can't have this
subjective human feedback loop built-in
that says well you know while the DP
thing is kind of cool we don't really
want to respect the random dice rolls we
sort of want to insert sort of our own
judgment about whether or not that dice
roll was okay and so this verse is kind
of a hard problem really with two two
facets to it one is the obvious one how
can review process is sort of reasonably
be structured so that we avoid this
problem but still get reasonably high
quality review and second if the sort of
restrictions in this category involve
just saying look the the way in which
people can make these kinds of
comparisons is is severely restricted of
what can be done with those comparisons
is even more restricted if that's the
case then how do you go about convincing
people especially people who aren't
going to be interested in digging
through the details of your code and
going and evaluating it on a bunch of
external data sets how do you convince a
group of folks like that that you have
generated a high-quality product or and
that there that's sort of free of bugs
so this is kind of a hard question right
because not everybody is working working
on these algorithms from the algorithms
end of it a lot of people are working on
it from sort of the we're interested in
the quality of the end data side of it
and so we need to have a way to reach to
these communities and say well look here
is a reasonable mechanism a reasonable
way for you to evaluate this data that
sort of feels reasonable to you and sort
of helps you build intuition about why
it is or isn't working the way it's
supposed to
this is another sort of apocryphal is
the wrong word but made-up stories so
this is a fictitious story that keeps me
up at night I have weird dreams I guess
so suppose in its production run that
the dash is his running and if there was
an exception
specifically SPARC there's an out of
memory exception I haven't described a
spark is yet which is a mistake but it's
sort of the large-scale parallelism
system that we use to organize most of
our computation across the cluster so
one of the things that likes to do is
say hey you're throwing way too many
memory requirements at me I'm just gonna
shut down and not finish this job and so
if that happens in the production run
I can imagine a future hopefully one
that won't happen and that we can sort
of organize our policies to avoid but I
can imagine a future where a friendly
engineer might ssh into one of the nodes
he's like oh this is really exciting and
like this is this cool new thing that's
running and maybe maybe the engineer
notices that the nodes are running close
to their full RAM usage and that they're
about to run out of memory and so given
this termination the engineer then says
well hey maybe for the next road we
should increase the size of the machines
that you're running these on so they do
that but on unbeknownst to us although
hopefully we would figure it out given
that it's like my example in this slide
the - may have thrown that error because
spare city was lower than we were
expecting I don't expect that there
would be a large variation since
porosity but there could be enough of a
enough of a jump that suddenly the
spares data structures we use all over
the place are not as efficient as we
thought they were we run out of RAM and
in the production run and so that's
great so far maybe then we get a bit
excited and we say hey there's this cool
in that newfangled thing that we design
that's intended to protect privacy
here's how we did it and specifically
we're going to go so far as to in the
name of the kinds of transparency and
the different so privacy allows us to
share with you we're then going to
release our machine specs - and say here
the CPU is here's the RAM here's all of
the specs for the machines be used but
unfortunately we now have this problem
where while the query Ram of top of
staff was was non differentially private
and I'm not sure that you can expose a
practical vulnerability based on this
but I also would rather not gamble on
that and sort of I I interpret most of
our move and in this direction as an
attempt to minimize these kinds of
things so so this sort of keeps me a
little bit up at night because it seems
very hard to nail this down especially
when you're in an organization that is
large and dispersed and where you as an
individual don't have sort of direct
control and access over all of these
systems
again not everybody is sitting down
studying differential privacy at night
necessarily okay so that's the first I
think it's not the last of the policy
issues actually I think I said that we
were moving to technical no he didn't
I'm sort of cause I technical so let's
remember so the actual sort of technical
facing implementation issues so just
want to mention I think probably lot of
folks in the audience are familiar if
you're not I recommend checking the
paper out it has been shown before will
serve some maybe two things to say
generally speaking naive implementations
of VP mechanisms can fail to actually be
DP and practice when you start taking
into account things that you haven't
modeled previously I don't think there's
anything super surprising about that
what is more interesting is that you lea
miranov showed I think it was a solo
paper could be misremembering but I
believe Helia showed that the difference
between floating-point numbers and the
reals that we usually use them to
approximate can actually be really
important for a difference like kind of
mechanisms and can totally undermine
your guarantee sometimes in highly
practically important ways and so this
was interesting to us because well as
sort of newcomers about two and a half
years ago to the EPA this kind of thing
was completely non-obvious to us and so
learning this we sort of became a bit
more aware I think of trying to watch
for a low-level assumptions that we were
making without realizing it and so we
started to wander across a few none of
these are I think necessarily entirely
novel issues but but they highlight the
kinds of problems that can sneak into a
DP implementation at scale especially if
you're sort of struggling to meet
problems of scale and so learning
systems that you weren't a complete
expert in when you moved into the into
the environment originally so one of
these involve some PI's marason twister
so most of the dass is implemented in
Python and numpy as a key library that
we use and a second is about spark and
the accidental sort of correlation
between streams random numbers so this
first one Mersenne twister the Mersenne
twister issue is interesting it's been
well known for a long time as far as I
can tell the Mersenne twister is not
cryptographically secure in any
reasonable sense and that you really
shouldn't be using it for sort of
security applications that being said
this is was not an area that I was an
expert in and so I was interested to
learn that oh wow Mersenne twister is
not something I should be relying on and
to learn furthermore that it's the only
pseudo-random number generator that is
by default available in numpy and there
appears to be at least in the current
commit of numpy no way to override it we
have some workarounds at this point that
are more and less hacky
which one we're talking about this was a
bit of a shock to me especially since
now I'm thinking about it in a bit more
detail I think this actually exposes
sort of a reasonably practical
vulnerability not just sort of a
theoretical failure in particular so the
way this is kind of blurry but the way
this function which is sort of copy and
pasted from the commit listed up there
works is this is an implementation of
Mersenne twister it spits out at the end
32-bit integer integers and those 32-bit
integers are generated primarily by
looking into a state of random numbers
that add better that are currently in
stock of 624 of those and sort of taking
one out and doing the sort of tempering
operations down here to them and every
time you go through six hundred and
twenty four consecutive random draws
simmers or draws from mere Sun twister
it then uses this sort of complex
looking stuff up here to say oh we've
reached the end of the length that
you're allowed to use we now need to
reset sort of our queue of available
random pseudo-random numbers and this is
that's what this stuff appears doing but
the key point is in between every 624
iterates that you draw from Marisa and
twister
it's not calling this sort of complex
looking code it's just kind of grabbing
whatever the next value is and feeding
it to this tempering operation and this
stuff down here is is completely
invertible and really cheaply invertible
and it's not even terribly hard to write
down some code that will invert that so
you can if you have direct access to
draws from our Sun twister for like ten
thousand iterations you can just go
through and say okay give me all those
draws island for each of them and then I
will just sort of walk back in
consecutive blocks until I figure out
which one of those plugged into this
part under the foal of the pool the
full-body embarrassin twister reproduces
all of the other observations I got from
Harrison twister and when you get that
then you know you have perfectly
reproduced or at least with high
confidence you know you've reproduced
the Mersenne twister state which means
you cannot predict all future draws from
Harrison twister which is a problem if
you're relying on iris and twister for
something like the - so let me mention
two switch slides of it earlier this is
sort of most of what I just said
the only thing on this slide that I
think I really want to highlight is this
stuff at the bottom so you there are a
few requirements to carry out that
attack Mersenne twister based attack the
most obvious one is you need at least
the modest number of draws from the
Mersenne twister sort of sort of
subroutine and it may not be obvious
that you can get that random many random
numbers but in the - if you remember the
billions upon billions in tabulations
that we're considering publishing that's
a lot of random numbers to look at even
within each geographic unit
we are publishing sort of at least 2,000
estimates for the pl 94 case and if that
is this own unique stream of Mersenne
twister iterates you have more than
enough to sort of try to carry out that
attack if you jump up to s if one
persons are hassled you this number is
500 thousand or million and you
definitely have enough there is some
stuff here that I'm hand waving maybe
should get to this part first so even
when you've seen those iterates those
are iterates typically and let's forget
about the post-processing for a second
which is another thing I'm gonna handle
Ava way but pretend that they are just
like little geometric mechanism or
Laplace mechanism will boss is easier
Laplace mechanism outputs so they all
look like the true value of x plus some
perturbation there is still sort of
extra extra inversion you need to do
because the implementation and numpy of
the Laplace distribution actually uses I
think two 32-bit integers not not just
one and not all of the operations are
sort of one-to-one invertible you feel a
little bit like that valued inversion
and then you need a that mostly means
that you need more than sort of the
lower bound number of numbers to carry
out this attack but I don't think
there's any reason you couldn't scale
that attack up and especially if you
have 500,000 or a million possible
outputs I don't think you could there's
any reason you couldn't figure out the
how to do that inversion and most
importantly it may also be the case that
when you look at each of those
individual values x + perturbation you
say well okay but there's also the true
value in there there's also the true
value in that x + perturbation so how do
I get to the true value I don't want the
true value I just want the perturbation
in order to carry out this attack how do
I get to the perturbation well when
you're generating this many values and
most of them are 0 it's not implausible
that an attacker could look at an
individual geographic unit and say well
I know there's only white people in that
block I know everybody's Caucasian there
because I know that most of the counts
that are published must have a true
value of 0 and that immediately tells me
what the perturbations look like exactly
for the remaining tabulations and that's
exactly sort of the fertile ground you
need to carry out this attack and so so
this is I think quite concerning and a
very good thing to try to avoid doing or
allowing so even though I have 5 minutes
left I'm gonna go quickly through this
next example the point of this example
is that if you're not familiar with
spark spark is a really nice system for
coordinating sort of cluster wide
parallelism spark sort of looks like
this and this is the toy issed of 20
examples you have a thing called a spark
the first one actually is ray
but it has a spark context underlying it
you call this parallelize operation to
say I want to take this sort of Python
list and I want to break it up into
units that can be distributed in tasks
across the the various cores available
online my machines in my cluster in this
case we're telling it slip this thing up
into two parts it's not a guarantee but
usually those two parts are going to be
the first two other ones and then the
last two elements if that is the case
you can then really quickly implement
the Laplace mechanism and I sort of
haven't put any of the constants in here
but you can pretend I did that you can
implement all the plots mechanism and
say okay well in here we're gonna map
over each of the elements that was in
our list and add Laplace wise to it and
sort of naively this looks like oh hey I
implemented like my very first applause
mechanism great in SPARC unfortunately
if you're not careful and you just do it
literally in this fashion on a spark
stand-alone implementation in a single
machine I haven't been able to so we
have been able to reproduce it on a
cluster just yet this yields a vector so
they were all zeros originally member a
vector in this case just all of the
perturbations with the property that x1
and x3 and x2 and x4 are perfectly
correlated and so this is a problem now
now our epsilon zooms off to infinity
when we were kind of hoping to hold it
down to a finite value and I thought
that's trouble we don't want that to
happen so this is sort of another
example of how a really useful system
for for enabling large-scale efficient
computation at the scale that we need
for a real world application
nevertheless sneaks in a whole bunch of
low-level problems that are kind of hard
to ferret out and make sure they don't
occur and then this is I think really
the problems are really one of my
interests here but if you help me tis
about to solve the problems that's what
this slide is about and then we'll drop
to sort of my closing thoughts so I have
this really long list which I'm gonna
I'm gonna drop one slide down and then
drunk on jump back up I don't really
want to go through them in detail
because these are mostly things that I
wanted to talk about today but didn't
have time to talk about we have a longer
list of things that are concerns in our
sort of practical barriers to
implementation for these large-scale
projects especially in the presence of
complex post-processing and then this is
a sort of a closing slide that says
we've done a lot of work and it's it's
we've gotten pretty far like they think
we're on track so to get where we want
to be
currently the - code is sufficient for
handling the peel menu forward on a
product
possibly with the inclusion
citizenship voting age table which is
not my decision but could very well be
there and then we're continuing scaling
tests for summary file one that's sort
of where we are currently at and trying
to take our code and say hey okay it
works your key will 94 with or without
citizenship voting age tables but can we
now move it to SF 1 with the current
code base and once we get to the point
where it actually functions on SF 1 then
we would like to say okay we know it's
actually not going to work for SF 2 or a
NSF
so now let's develop sort of an entirely
different approach for those and I we
have shared a few ideas about how to do
that but that is part for myself of
topic and there's a lot of conversation
that needs to happen around that but I
think it's going to be sort of fun and
painful but also fun working through the
rest of those problems and so I will
close by just sitting on a slide thank
you
questions even you've mentioned a couple
of times that you in the various
headaches consistency headaches that
that you're looking down on having to be
consistent so I could see two kinds of
problem one is computational on the
other is loss of privacy budget can you
point to the places where because of in
some sense arbitrary restrictions you're
spending much more of your privacy
budget than you would like in other
words if you didn't have to be
consistent
didn't have to have I and so on how much
would that liberate you and in which
parts of your work would it liberate the
most so I think the biggest impact that
dropping invariance and I also throw in
sort of the micro to the requirement
that we produce microdata dropping those
two requirements would mostly know that
representation of here it would mostly
have taken a period of a year to a
year-and-a-half of work that was
entirely focused not on optimizing sort
of the the accuracy privacy trade-off
but was instead focused on saying as we
walk down this tree we need to know that
there's not going to come a point at
which the algorithm just says well I
can't make microdata that is consistent
with all the requirements you've given
me it would mostly take that amount that
that period of time and allow us to
instead convert it into trying to
improve the privacy accuracy trade-off
which I don't think quite speaks to loss
of privacy lost budget or or gain and
privacy lost budget from from dropping
those requirements but it but I think
does speak to sir the amount of time
that is diverted from sort of the
primary activity it's also difficult
because things like the invariants in
particular don't there isn't really a
clean translation as far as I'm aware of
them into sort of a this is the amount
of privacy lost metric we've lost
because we imposed these invariants you
sort of double the privacy loss because
you can't have inverses out you have to
keep the total number of it right and
you can you can sort of tap those
arguments to things like Blowfish
privacy and some of the other frameworks
that that have sort of privacy lost
major still associated with them I think
what we've seen is mostly if we were to
do a free to take that route to
quantifying the effects on our semantic
guarantees of these additional sort of
restrictions that we have that the the
guarantees would be very very bad on the
epsilon Zin practice for almost any sort
of standard value would be would be
massive when we actually look at sort of
how the posterior odds ratios that we're
trying to bound the --have we have
alternatives to those that we've tried
to work out semantic score that are more
nicely behaved but instead of trying to
sort of bound the worst case under an
alternative the definition that respects
the various restrictions imposed we
instead try to say things like well
there are certain attackers classes of
attackers and there are also certain
hypotheses that we just can't guard
against and so that is a
mm somewhat more fraught exercise and a
little bit further from sort of the a
deal of guarding against all possible
attackers that we kind of like to be
close to but but giving those things up
has enabled us to sort of drag the the
bound on posterior odds ratios in those
sorts of objects a little bit back down
to earth I can share some of that after
if you're interested in I think we have
some of that in a point where well I
thought let's look at it a bit but first
of all thank you for this alike you gave
five talks in so there's a lot that you
might have said that I missed but I'm
gonna ask the questions and you'll tell
me the first one is at the very end you
said the new new measurements and forms
of data collection something to that
effect in one of your last nights and
I'm curious what you just taught me when
you see the slicer for the very very end
so here post-party new finals up I think
anyway but so you make the point in here
different measurement and microdata
generation method in your quest point I
was wondering oh for us of two and a
half yeah yeah my second question is
related to this issue that you mentioned
sort of two thoughts along the way that
the having knowledge about particular
census block and the absence of people
and he said that can be solved but I was
wondering
what how are you going about that who
makes the decision on you know how much
technology can happen and you make this
example if you know they had no black
people in the block and you put someone
in I mean that I didn't really fully
understand what you have in place
systemically - so I'll take the first
question first and jump to the second
question so so for the first question I
will say first the this this passage
about meeting fundamentally sort of
different measurement of my creditor
nation method is very specific to us of
to nai NSF and the really what's driving
this is just that throughout the rest of
the algorithm we have these massive
histogram objects wandering around and
they're usually reasonably compact
because they're very sparse but the the
ones that contain measurements are
although a lot less fares and so when we
move to a step two and a NSF we know
that those history objects are gonna be
a thousand times larger and there's just
no way to store them so instead we need
some sort of iterative algorithm that
will just store exactly what we need
when we need it and we'll sort of throw
away and reclaim memory as needed and I
think we can achieve that for us up to
an eye NSF and my guests for why that's
possible is that the primary thing
driving our need for those complex large
histograms was without the complex large
histograms they enable us to do to
handle the complex invariants of address
f2 and I NSF once you've conditioned
don't have any sort of dealt with us up
one the remaining sort of stuff that has
to be done doesn't really involve
complex invariants and then for your
second question which I think was about
who decides or systemically how'd you
figure out how much knowledge is
allowable I think the reality is that
there is not a good answer for that
question which is why we have tried do
only partake in any sort of exercises of
that kind when it is absolutely required
which is so when we're dealing with the
invariance there's it doesn't seem to be
avoidable if we're asked to choose
between or to provide guidance to others
to choose between invariants at the
block level versus the state but the
summation level or somesuch
then we need to try and reason about
those kinds of things but for the final
guarantees we're trying to do our best
not to make decisions sort of personally
on on how much knowledge is reasonable
to allow because I think that is a very
difficult thing that's sort of why it's
attractive to move towards these very
broad guarantees and I try not to harm
them too much oh okay
so this Thanks